am I the only one who goes to these
movies strictly for the minions
Despicable Me 2 stars the voices of
Steve Carell and Kristen Wiig and in
this movie we have GRU who's now he's
like a father figure you know he's got
these three girls he's not a big
supervillain anymore but his skills are
still needed because Kristen Wiig plays
this super spy who is part of the super
spy organization the needs grew to
figure out who this guy is who works at
a mall who probably has like this
dangerous serum and they need to figure
out who he is it could be any one of the
vendors in the mall so him and her
stakeout and a little cupcake store in
the mall to try to figure out who this
guy is Despicable Me was a film that I
enjoyed I saw it once you know I had a
good time with it my favorite part of
the whole movie were the minions for
sure I mean these little yellow guys
that run around saying stuff they're not
really speaking English but you get a
sense of what they're saying I think
that's what makes them so clever even
though they're not speaking the English
language you can still understand what
they're saying now one of the things I
really liked about the first film was
the adult humour there was quite a bit
of it actually and it wasn't like dirty
or anything but it wasn't strictly a
kids film and I really liked that about
the first one and this film has possibly
even more actually because there are a
lot of moments in this movie where none
of the kids in the audience were
laughing and all the adults were
chuckling including myself and I found
that a lot of fun about Despicable Me 2
and for that reason I think this works
is a sequel because it's a film that
people of all ages can really enjoy you
get to learn a little bit more about the
character of GRU in this movie he didn't
have the greatest childhood in regards
to girls and when he gets stuck on this
stakeout with this other female spy you
know there's there's hints of romance
there and the three little girls he
takes care of don't have a mother figure
and so there's actually a nice
underlying depth to the film in regards
to that and I think that's something
that would be good for kids to see but
at the same time it actually has quite a
bit of adult humor that I found myself
really enjoying it there's actually a
few times the movie I was like wow I
can't believe that's actually in there
because they got away with some stuff
movie has very impressive animation as
well I saw it in 3d I wouldn't say it's
absolutely necessary to see this movie
in 3d in fact I'd rarely say that about
movies at all really but the 3d in the
movie is good and the animation like I
said it all looks beautiful but despite
the fact that the animation is good the
voice acting is top-notch and there is
good action and humor in the movie there
is actually a great sense of depth to
the film and towards the end of the
movie as certain things are coming
together I felt to my
shame you know I was kind of into it can
I say it was uh it was nice it's not
strictly a kid's film you know adults
can go to this movie and find the
enjoyment in it but it's not adult film
at all it's something that everyone can
really enjoy because of those minions I
gotta say the minions in this movie that
those guys save this whole movie
honestly like without them this movie
wouldn't be funny like at all like
they're hilarious in this movie and they
get a lot of screen time so if you were
annoyed by them in the first one stay
away because they are definitely front
and center in this movie but I'm telling
you like everything out of those guys
Mouse funny hilarious truly there's
nothing that much more to it if you want
to watch a whole bunch of minions tell
jokes and watch GRU be silly and
slapstick and humor and then have a nice
heartwarming hug at the end with your
kids or your nephews or your friends or
whatever or a girlfriend maybe possibly
girlfriends Despicable Me 2 is a fun
time in the theaters it's a good sequel
but I wouldn't say it's like this big
movie you have to see it's not like at
the depths of Pixar greatness that you
see but it is a fun time and I'm going
to give Despicable Me to Abby thanks as
always for watching guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
Oh